dip it into some mustard on the second
bite it's it's not one no sorry what did
you just say i said i dip it into
mustard on the section what did you do
in the first bite i bite it
then i go to mustard for the second bite
see you're a pig
what you're biting it and then you're
dipping it in the mustard not a
community mustard i put it a little on
my own plate
you didn't say that oh [ __ ] you
sal at the last super bowl party did you
see him with his own dip he's seen me
with a million dips i've never dipped
twice ever ever he probably double dips
he probably double dips i'll keep an eye
on her from now on
you're telling me that you make your own
mustard from the other mustard i pick up
one of the little plates made available
at any decent party spread and i take a
disposable spoon and i scoop some of my
own mustard into this thing and i take
one of the little breaks made available
if i were to dip after i bit i flip it
and go unbit end into the dip okay well
that's what you should be doing you want
a cookie for it is that legal though
with covert is that legal i know i don't
even know this is all pre-covered i
haven't been to a super bowl party in
six years at this point
joe
a cocktail weenie is is look it has its
place i like him but it is that's what
the that's what them by the way that's
what the whites used to say about all
other uh races in this country they have
their place
god don't do that don't project